nous accueillons notre invité du samedi
20 heures ce soir jean christophe
parisot constat
alors jean christophe parisot la
question de l'intégration des handicapés
dans nos sociétés modernes reste un
combat un combat dans lequel vous jouez
un rôle capital
condamné par une myopathie à l'âge de 10
ans vous êtes devenu le premier étudiant
handicapé
diplômé de sciences po avant de devenir
le premier sous-préfet en fauteuil
quinze ans plus tard voilà aujourd'hui
vous racontez votre incroyable parcours
dans un livre intitulé préfet d autres
publié chez des clés de brouwer un autre
visage de l'état on en parle à 20 heures
[Musique]
jean christophe parisot un bon soir au
sort vous n'êtes ni le 20 juin 1967 à
douala au cameroun père ingénieur mère
femme au foyer
et puis à votre grand père résistant
mort en déportation
pour qui vous avez une admiration
absolue derrière vous portez ce cheval
hier à la main gauche c'est lui qui vous
a donné le courage dont vous avez fait
montre par la suite la certitude qu'on
peut donner il s'agit pour les autres
ouais il a du sens même si on ne me
rateront de trois ans 5 la centration
alors dans la famille parizeau tout va
bien foyer aimant
jusqu'au jour où votre maman apprend que
ses trois enfants
succomberont à une maladie évolutive
une forme rare de myopathie qui
s'appelle l'alpha sarko blick anneaux
pâtit il va la dirso line qui touche 150
personnes en france
si miley qui provoque la paralysie
progressive du corps et qui ne laisse
espérer que quelques années de survie en
fait
après le diagnostic vous avez dix ans à
l'époque vous continuez à marcher et
votre corps se détériore de jour en jour
les chutes se multiplient notamment dans
la cour de récréation et vos jambes sont
de moins en moins fiables on peut dire
que c'est hiroshima dans la vie d'un
enfant de perdre progressivement ses
bras et ses jambes ouais
à l'époque les pronostics les plus fous
circulent on dit la myopathie et presque
vaincu hélas le rythme de la recherche
n'est pas celui des malades
malgré le grand espoir du téléthon qui
continuent à être implanté sport la
dégradation la souffrance sont au rendez
vous les a il faut se battre 8 et
j'oserais
alors en attente de la thérapie génique
vous êtes le cobaye de tout un tas
d'expérimentation injection électrique
bain bouillant chaussures orthopédiques
médicaments absolument inutile en plus
on vous dit à l'époque que vous serez
incapable d'apprendre les tables de
multiplication et ce qu'il faut bien que
parfois la médecine de limites ouais
petit à petit votre corps se
recroqueville vous découvrez les
attelles de nuit les corps sept jours et
puis un jour alors que la sonnerie tous
les élèves se précipite dans la cour
pour retrouver leurs parents vous chuté
lourdement
et là en larmes le visage couvert de
feuilles mortes vous serrer les poings
pour vous relever
et le chauffeur qui vient vous chercher
est obligé de vous porter et vous pose
sur la banquette arrière comme un comme
un paquet j'ai compris sur 20 que ma vie
avait basculé que désormais je rentrais
dans un autre univers celui des autres
le titre de mon livre je veux les autres
c'était l'indépendance c'est à dire le
combat pour survivre
ces jours là vous comprenez que vous ne
serez plus dans la cour de récréation
mais vous serez à l'intérieur et que
vous regarderez vos copains jouer à
travers une vitre complètement je tombe
dans une sorte de réfugiés au monde et
je décide ce jour là à s'en sortir
malgré tout
là vous découvrez la vision un fauteuil
tout à fait indépendant ce jour et nuit
le fait est différent qu'on porte un
regard différent sur vous ok les chances
ne sont pas eux mêmes
alors on vous met dans un centre
spécialisé une espèce de mouroir dorée
où il ya des dizaines de petits mis aux
pattes sanglés dans des fauteuils et qui
guette par la fenêtre l'arrivée d'une
maman dont j'ai la chance de ne pas y
rester longtemps mais en même temps ce
jour là je me suis dit ces enfants là si
un jour je suis un endroit où je peux
parler comme sur ce plateau de télé je
parlerai pour eux je dirais qu'ils ont
existé qu'ils ont une vie mais je
parlerai je serai leur porte-parole
[Applaudissements]
la ceni loisirs ni école ni télé
et un jour il ya une scène terrible aux
parents décident de vous emmener au
cinéma
et on vous laisse pas entrer parce qu'on
dit qu'il ya des problèmes d'évacuation
quelqu'un qui est dans un fauteuil et
c'est assez compliqué et votre père
intervient son père prend la parole
devant la foule et dit à tout le monde
mais mon fils ne peut pas rentrer d'un
cinéma que tout ce qu'ils soient
solidaires avec nous avec le mouvement
avec mon fils avancez fasse un pas en
avant et ce jour là personne n'a bougé
il en a rangé le fauteuil dans le coffre
et on est rentrés à la maison et ce jour
noir je me suis dit mais qu'est ce qu'il
faut faire pour faire changer les
mentalités qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
pour susciter cet élan de fraternité qui
donne envie de vivre ensemble va vous
dit j'ai pas vu le film ce jour là mais
j'ai plus appris sur l'homme qu'en
envoyant une centaine a été une grande
pédagogie pour moi
l'heure à 13 ans nos dernières forces
disparaissent vous entré définitivement
dans ce que vous appelez le monde des
handicapés comme on dit je dire
handicapées et au collège vous découvrez
la cruauté des adolescents est ce qui
est extraordinaire finalement ségo seul
pote d'assez des gens différents c'est
un exilé yougoslave et un fils de
dollars quand ils ont compris que
parfois on peut vivre en prison quelque
part dans son propre pays ont passé j'y
vais dans son propre pays
puis vous rencontrez un anarchiste qui
vous fait découvrir la politique et là
votre activité intellectuelle va
décupler c'est à dire que vous commencez
à lire à regarder documentaire à lire
les magazines enfin vous devenez fou de
politique complètement j'ai compris qu'à
citer c'était mon objectif est que la
vie ensemble elle devait absolument
compter sur des personnes différentes
mais comme moi comme d'autres qui ont
d'autres différence c'est que là on
pouvait pas vivre dans une société où
tourner ça paraît simple
heureusement vous rencontré katia
allier une scène terrible dans votre
livre c'est qu'à un moment pour montrer
votre amour l'un pour l'autre vous
traversez la cour en on vous donnant la
main pour afficher votre relation elle a
peur évidemment elle se dit est-ce que
c'est pas de la pitié finalement est-ce
que je l'aimais vraiment et ça continue
une fille sera ordinaire que j'ai connu
j'avais 16 ans well aujourd'hui on a
quatre enfants et je vois la mariée
depuis 21 ans ouais
évidemment vous comprenez que vos rêves
idyllique ne se réaliseront jamais et
que c'est pas vous qui la porterait dans
vos bras mais elle qui vous portera dans
ses bras
très touchant votre livre
là vous décidez de faire sciences po pas
ce que vous dites je vais être
scolarisés parce que ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est qu'on considère que les
handicapés on ne sait pas la peine
qu'ils aillent à l'école donc en fait
qu'est-ce qu'ils font pas ils n'ont pas
de boulot et il gagne 600 euros par mois
enfin dire qu'on leur donne vous vous
comprenez ça évidemment vous refusez de
vivre avec 600 euros par mois je décide
de me battre pour faire sciences po
personne n'est jamais rentré en fauteuil
roulant et ans tétraplégique et donc je
décide d'assister aux cours dans les
couloirs parce que les portes ne
permettent pas de rentrer avec mon
fauteuil donc il ya les cours dans les
amphis et moi j'écoute à la porte les
cours on me donne des notes on me donne
des photocopies je travaille ma fou pour
réussir ce fichu diplôme que j'obtiens
et vous obtenez vous dites j'ai
travaillé jusqu'aux larmes d'épuisement
complètement je savais que l'enjeu de ma
vie était là il fallait absolument que
je trouve qu une personne différente ou
vers les compétences et réussir son
diplôme de sciences pour même s'il n'a
pas un visage de ses mains ni de ses
jambes
là vous travaillez au conseil général
des hauts-de-seine alors évidemment
c'est un boulot pourri quoi vous
découpez des gravures dans un livre je
suis catégorie c donc je sais ce que
c'est qu'à touba de shon 1 je
travaillais dans une cuve elle éclairée
au néon boléro avec des gens qui sont
tout à fait extraordinaire parce que
sont très divers services publics un jeu
d trouve pas ce que c'est que le service
public
est là quand on vous dit mais pourquoi
tu fais ça tu est diplômé de sciences po
vous dites il faut bien payer
l'électricité les coquillettes
exactement comment je vois les mêmes ça
n'a pas fait peur de faire souffrir
alors évidemment vous militez pour les
personnes handicapées vous rédiger un
livre blanc que vous remettez à françois
bayrou qui à l'époque et une éducation
nationale on va vous commencez à à
lutter pour l'épauler gens comme vous et
puis un jour vous écrivez un petit livre
humoristique
sur les élections qui tombent entre les
mains de gilles de robien qui vous
engage comme plume voilà pendant 18 ans
jusqu'à sa plume un conseiller en
communication politique
et ensuite en 2007 après un rendez vous
à l'elysée avec claude guéant vous serez
nommé sous-préfet de cahors alors ça
c'est vraiment un grand coup dans ma vie
parce que je me suis dit pourquoi je ne
serais pas sous préfet je suis docteur
en sciences politiques
je suis diplômée de sciences po j'ai
l'expérience de travail kaminis y avait
aucune raison que je n'y arrive pas je
veux voir pour dire et redire me pose
cette question est ce que vous sentez
capable de faire je dis oui je suis
nommé quatre heures plus tard
il sera beaucoup pardonné à claude
guéant
et en 2010 ce sera montpellier je suis
aujourd'hui sous préfet chargé de la
cohésion sociale et l'égalité des
chances en languedoc-roussillon mais
j'évolue effet ce livre ont montré que
j'ai vécu une histoire complètement
dingue je veux dire une histoire de fou
mais qui peut peut-être aider certaines
personnes à se dire eh bien j'ai des
talents il faut que j'aie mettre en
oeuvre peut-être que je doute trop de
moi même mais j'ai un horizon j'ai envie
de vivre il faut aller le plus loin
possible mon témoignage c'est de dire la
vie est belle il faut croire on à vis
d'elle france un grand et beau pays qui
m'a donné la chance d'être sous préfet
et j'invite toutes les personnes
handicapées avec leur talent de faire au
mieux de se battre il faut jamais
capitulé war
alors
il ya un passage absolument
extraordinaire dans votre livre c'est
une cérémonie au monument aux morts le
sac alors sous préfet tétraplégique
trachéotomisés qui passe en revue les
troupes alors extraordinaire rencontrent
un véritable séisme qui s'est passé ce
jour là en france 1 les joueuses veut
dire pour la première fois un homme
ainsi portant un uniforme et les
feuilles de chêne qui représente la
force
ainsi défilent et passe en revue des
troupes debout et donc c'est ces
militaires ses papiers ces gendarmes me
vois passer mais france à lui et après
la cérémonie viennent me voir j'ai eu
des officiers qui sont venus boire comme
dit on a vécu un moment extraordinaire
ça a été un immense honneur pour nous
[Applaudissements]
bouleversée ouais je te quitte
enfin moi je suis ton histoire m'a
laissé sans voix puis
c'est nous les handicapés spots
commercy franchement solide c'est dingue
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu